Facebook has a new privacy policy that
absolutely nobody Facebook updated its
community standards guidelines giving
users more clarity on what it sees as an
acceptable post a corner to the new
guidelines this look will take down
graphic images when they're shared for
sadistic pleasure or to celebrate or
glorify violence nudity will also be
removed in many cases but allow for
images of breastfeeding art and medical
conditions a blog post from Facebook
said in part these standards are
designed to create an environment where
people feel motivated and empowered to
treat each other with empathy and
respect for people to treat each other
with empathy and respect which is
exactly what the Internet's all about it
so I always find these stories hilarious
because whenever facebook does anything
remember they change anything first off
we all sign it right nobody reads the 80
you have a lawyer on retainer with you
at all times every time you have to sign
something no but my father is an
attorney so I definitely take advantage
of that yeah I mean nobody does it right
we judge that not all three men know but
with other things right you have your
dad I'll use him too but really we just
we just click it and then that's a fact
but I always think it's funny that
everyone goes crazy every time they
change something
except correct me if I'm wrong but isn't
it a free service that no one's forcing
you to use yeah my favorite is when
people put that little disclaimer up
like you do not have the right to use my
photo it's not legally binding right
that's not that's not tasteless in your
status yeah you're like wow you went out
of the way to put a watermark on this
thing I don't think that's gonna do
anything so this is the part the people
don't get like they're giving us these
free services and the whole point of
these of them giving it to us for free
is because they're taking us they're
taking our information and if they want
to control it in a certain way and not
let us put porn on there or violence or
whatever really you have no right to
stop them right well I think Facebook
and then when my mom joined you know
it's kind of been for me for a while
yeah but secondly it said that it's
funny it said that they won't they're
gonna ban pictures that protect Laura
fight violence so I can't put a boxing
videos at UFC videos right we can't put
up about videos of war how about a video
of you know when I went to the Rose Bowl
this year they flew the b-1 bomber over
and everybody cheered a bomb
Baumer yeah I'm killing machine so is
that also glorifying violence I think it
is you can't put pictures of the b-1
bomber up so again it's another [ __ ]
people trying to control other people's
morality and you can't do it right and
they also said they would ban nudity
unless it was for art reasons so so I
guess Mapplethorpe could put up his rice
flash because that's art it is breast
feeding or medical problem they said
arts own art and they also said for very
artistic reasons so I'm like so
Mapplethorpe could put a picture of
Pitts Christ up and Facebook would be
okay with that right so I'll get it it's
[ __ ] you can't control people's
morality and that's what they're trying
to they're trying to make us be good
people and you can't do it right and
that's the thing what that I never
understand what this stuff is all of
this is online whatever you want
whatever degree of value I want to see
whatever degree of sex you want to see I
mean this goes to the Twitter
conversation we were having earlier
about anonymous but they can't
ultimately they can't control it and if
people want it aren't they just gonna go
somewhere else for it yeah but that's
the whole point I maybe think they're
probably trying to limit their own
liability right they're just trying to
put some parameters on what they can be
responsible for down the line if you
verify violence and someone gets killed
and they say oh it's it's like the old
rock but you know rock and roll made him
do it or the Twinkie defense
yeah video games made a billion yeah we
should o study started on that one yeah
but I think that they're probably just
trying to protect themselves legally and
that's why they put these things in
place so that down the line god forbid
something happens they're protected I
don't think they think it's actually
gonna dictate anybody's choices or or
morality you're not gonna be a horrible
person and say you know what because I'm
gonna be nice oh yeah it's not gonna be
them do you guys do you guys think in a
weird way that we're sort of conditioned
to accept these controls you know to me
like television is totally controlled
right the FCC says what we can and can't
say in seven dirty words and all that
kind of stuff and the internet was
totally free for a long time it was like
this great Wild West and now something's
changing we're now it's like we're
causing the internet to start censoring
our set like we're doing it to ourselves
as well it seems to me that if people
really want to Facebook to be free they
they would revolt against Facebook but
in a way we want these controls well
where were you know that
entire world societies will be becoming
more brutal and angry and mean you know
for proof of this just go to any YouTube
video check out the comments section
never read the comments do you not know
this I'm gonna talk directly over there
because I know that our commenters are
not like that for summary we've done
something good here our commenters are
good people but what's your theory you
have a theory about the theory that the
fourth comments are always mercilessly
rips the third commenter
yeah and then the fifth commenter comes
in and tries to find common ground above
everybody and for that the sixth
commenter impinges sexuality right
okay so let's break this right now down
below what's going on down there I
wanted up for some reason we I don't
know how we did it it's a freaking
miracle but ours let's keep our on point
and good and all that stuff anyway prove
me right here people what do you think
about this should Facebook be censoring
some of this stuff should it just be a
free-for-all do we want these controls
on ourselves in some weird bizarre
dystopian future let us know in those
comments right down
[Music]